Thank you very much, now let's go for the answer. Let us discuss the options one by one.
First, print "This can't happen". Cool, it's going to go to the console,
probably going to go to some log but it is unlikely that anyone will ever notice this,
and this means that our traffic light, well in our simulation, will be in some undefined state,
possibly meaning that the traffic will also be in some undefined state.
What happens if we have multiple traffic lights and one of them is neither red nor yellow nor green?
Ow, this is going to cause lots and lots of interesting issues.
So simply printing this out to the console is not enough.
This problem is too hard: we are violating the data invariant here, which also rules out the last option.
That's not a good option. Now for the two remaining choices and this is a tough choice.
We could have the assertion in here, assert fault, which would be nice but keep in mind
that this could actually also be turned off,
for instance, when invoking the Python interpreter with -0.
However, in this particular situation, there's no reason to turn this assertion off
because well, if it gets executed then it raises an exception immediately
and if it does not get executed then everything is fine,
meaning that by turning it off, we don't get any savings.
So the better option is simply to raise an assertion exception plain and simple
and thereby to document that something is going really wrong in the program.
This will not hurt performance at all obviously because it will only be triggered
when all other checks already have failed.
However, if these were the production program, you may wish to come up
with some global try catch block in the program
or in Python this would be a global try except block that would catch all assertion exceptions
and then pop up a dialogue saying "Oh we encountered a fatal error" possibly offering
some recovery mechanism or some ability to save the progress that we've seen so far
such that the user is not confronted simply with all of his work disappearing.